ça fait partie des classiques des
campagnes électorales estivale pourriez
thomas mulcair dans une épluchette de
blé d'inde ça c'est des images de samedi
à saint-girons mais ils en feront comme
ça des centaines et des centaines des
bûchettes de blé d'inde ce qui est
différent par contre cette fois ci dans
cette campagne électorale c'est que pour
la première fois de son histoire chef du
npd peut prétendre gagner devenir
premier ministre et un des grands défis
de thomas mulcair c'est de convaincre
les canadiens que son programme plus à
gauche ne créera pas de déficit
je lui ai parlé il ya quelques minutes
monsieur mulcair bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur roy monsieur le coeur est ce
qu'on doit vous appelez au québec thomas
ou tom cassée nouveau est ce que c'est
pour adoucir votre image petit nom de
temps en fait tom a toujours été le
petit nom des proches sont la famille et
les amis de plus longue date vont
m'appeler en garde 3 me ce qui ferait
sans doute sur certains au npd parce que
cette année les fondateurs mais atome a
toujours été mon nom en français thomas
mulcair mais j'ai eu tellement de
prononciation il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont dit ça va du plus simple de le
raccourcir à top alors voilà lorsqu'on
utilise le plus mais j'ose échappe
je fais des blagues mais n'empêche en
campagne électorale image est importante
oui est ce qu'on vous a dit parce qu'on
vous a conseillé puis sûr que oui mais
je veux vraiment vous allez me le dire
d'être plus souriant plus plus gentils
entre guillemets parce que vous aviez en
chambre à la chambre l'image d'un
pitbull là qui va régler des questions
difficiles
bin l'un empêche pas l'autre mais j'ai
surtout catherine qui a pris un peu de
répit de sa carrière très chargé comme
psychologue dans le secteur public et
privé et elle m'accompagne donc ça aide
d'avoir un plus grand sourire je dois
vous avouer patrice est menée sur oise
ne devrait pas vous surprendre de mon
temps dit que c'est pas toujours apte à
vous donner le sourire spontané
quand vous êtes face à stephen harper
tous les jours et c'est pourtant mon
rôle à la chambre des communes alors
c'est vrai que c'est parfois un peu plus
rude est coriace mais pendant cette
campagne on a des idées positives clair
que ce qu'on ferait différemment on veut
défaire et remplacer les conservateurs
de stephen harper puis on a des bonnes
idées pour
création d'emplois aider les personnes
plus âgées dans notre société et on est
en train d'émettre l'avant on va en
parler justement de ce programme parlons
de votre promesse phare les garderies
370 mille places pour un première phase
qui prenait 4 1
combien ça coûtera au gouvernement
fédéral ça quand on l'a annoncé au mois
d'octobre de l'année dernière on avait
pu apporter avec nous tout est chiffré
dans le moindre et au terrain année par
année et le nombre de sièges de chaque
fois tout comme notre problème dans son
entier il va avoir des documents qui
vont chiffres et chaque engagement
d'où va venir l'argent et comment on va
le payer ok mais combien ça va coûter à
terme des huit ans parce que c'est un un
programme sur huit ans on parle d'un
chiffre de 5 milliards
mais la première année ces quelques
centaines de millions et combien ça va
coûter aux provinces parce que ce que
vous vous proposez vous le dit pas
souvent mais les provinces de vent ou si
donné leur part en fait on dit à chaque
fois que c'est un programme partagé 60%
par le fédéral 40% par les provinces et
on dit surtout que ça ne va pas être mur
à mur le même programme à travers le
canada parce qu'il ya des choses qui
varient par exemple il ya quelques
provinces dont l'ontario qui ont deux
années de maternelle qu'ils ont coûté
cher on va en tenir compte lorsqu'on va
négocier mais le plus important c'est
qu'à travers le canada
les gens sont en train de dire la même
chose que les québécois ont réalisé
comme service de garderie aborde à bas
prix disponibles c'est bon pour les
familles c'est surtout bon pour les
femmes qui ont souvent seulement fondées
mais caporal cas vous voulez donner
l'impulsion ce programme mais les
provinces
si l'ontario dit non merci ben il y aura
pas garderez votre programme en ontario
si l'alberta dit non merci en europe en
alberta donc c'est un rêve que vous avez
mais c'est encore à l'étape du rêve
non c'est un programme très bien été
quand vous avez marre
les marques the friendly de ce monde et
les pierre fortin qui regarde son tour
la structure tantôt les chiffres c'est
que c'est bien préparés et on est prêt à
aller de l'avant
on n'en thériault j'étais rassuré au
mois de novembre
quelques semaines après notre lancement
le gouvernement libéral de l'ontario a
voté pour notre proposition la
proposition du npd d'avant
les garderies à 15 heures par jour à
travers l'ontario donc on a bon espoir
qu'ils vont vouloir ce soir et mettre ça
en place mais pour cent de la facture
payée par les provinces et au québec
comme un programme qui coûte déjà assez
cher merci on va en parler dans une
seconde
combien vous enverriez le chèque au
québec ce serait de combien mais vous
avez raison juste pour terminer là
dessus les femmes souvent sont celles
qui doivent faire des choix très
difficiles dans leur carrière ce qu'on a
vu au québec c'est 70 mille femmes ont
pu réintégrer le marché du travail et à
donner plus d'argent dans les coffres du
gouvernement que ça m'a coûté non
seulement c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
se permettre de faire c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut pas se permettre de ne
pas faire le québec effectivement au
terme de ce que nous on appelle la
déclaration de sherbrooke qui est notre
position de base en matière
constitutionnelle
on dit que lorsqu'une dépenses fédérales
dans une domaine exclusif de compétences
des provinces transfert direct de la
somme totale sans condition j'ai envoyé
un chèque au québec consultez le québec
on aime quelqu'un on l'a chiffrée de
mémoire à terme ce serait de l'ordre de
1 milliard de dollars sauf à parfaire ok
vous avez dit que pour payer ce genre de
programme et drôle parce que vous avez
d'autres propositions dans votre
programme bien sûr que vous alliez pas
aussi les impôts des canadiens sauf les
grands les corporations quittent
actuellement à 15 pour ça les po1
corporatif à combien vous allez le aussi
l'impôt soyons précis mais je vais être
pressé je vais l'annoncer en cours de
campagne et on parle d'une augmentation
raisonnable de l'impôt des grandes
corporations parce que tous les
canadiens paient leur juste part sauf
les grandes sociétés
monsieur trudeau monsieur harper sont
d'accord là dessus ils ont voulu occuper
les conservateurs 50 milliards de
dollars de réductions d'impôts pour les
grandes sociétés au canada monsieur
trudeau a pris ça ils vont partir de 15
à 16 à 17
on va l'annoncer où on va l'annoncer en
cours de campagne quand on est en train
de bouger
mais je ne veux pas le dire là parce que
ça va faire l'objet d'une autre annonce
en temps et lieu qu'est ce que nous
allons faire et je sache je peux vous
donner le chiffre les pme les petites et
moyennes entreprises créées 80% des
nouveaux emplois au canada nous va leur
donner une réduction d'impôt d'eau
en supposant qu'il est à l'heure
actuelle 1 9% ça ça va aider à la
création d'emplois justement monsieur
mulquin vous annoncer ces baisses
d'impôts l' augmentation verra de
combien pour les grandes corporations
si vous arrivez la première année que
j'étais lui vous êtes le premier
ministre et que vous voyez que compte
tenu de la baisse du prix du pétrole qui
s'accentue contenu d'un éventuel
ralentissement économique
vous n'avez pas les moyens d'aller de
l'avant un nouveau programme se soit
garderie autres qu'est-ce que vous
choisissez déficit ou vous mettez la
[ __ ] 2 sur vos programmes
gouverner c'est faire des choix comme
vous le savez j'ai déjà siéger à un
conseil des ministres je sais ce que
c'est de faire ces choix difficiles jour
après jour et je vais être capable
justement dans notre premier exercice
complet nous n'oubliez pas qu'on va
arriver en plein milieu de l'ex-société
monsieur harper moi je garantis rien sur
l'état des livres pour lui mais je peux
vous dire qu'un gouvernement du npd va
faire la même chose qu'il a toujours
fait nous avons du npd a le meilleur
bilan de déséquilibres budgétaires de
toutes les touristes ont visité renoncer
à certains de vos engagements plus
sociaux 10 ans pour arriver à un déficit
zéro
non je n'ai jamais dit ça et je ne le
dirai jamais ce que j'ai annoncé par
exemple aujourd'hui une augmentation du
supplément de revenu garanti pour aider
les 200000 est né au canada qui vivent
dans la pauvreté puis pour l'heure
d'année assez d'argent pour sortir de la
pauvreté
ça ne changerait pas pour moi comme
social-démocrate mon but premier dans la
vie politique c'est de réduire les
inégalités et de créer des ok je me suis
dit que je voulais reposer parce que là
c'est important les gens vous regardent
là et vous est d'ailleurs le premier
chef du npd
vous avez des possibilités réelles de
devenir premier ministre du canada donc
entre faire un déficit si l'économie
n'est pas au rendez-vous ou abandonnés
des programmes des promesses que vous
avez qu'est-ce que vous choisissez
c'est un faux choix ce genre de choix
que moi je refuse de dire que c'est la
seule possibilité la manière que vous
posez la question c'est comme si j'étais
obligé de garder tous les choix de
stephen harper et si je veux ajouter
quelque chose ça exige des nouvelles sam
je vous annonce rien quand je vous dis
que je n'ai pas les mêmes priorités que
nous on est un gouvernement social
démocrate on va faire des choses
différemment certains de ses choix par
exemple le fameux partage de revenus
c'est des milliards dans la reprise à
même la classe moyenne pour donner à la
tranche la plus fortunée les 15%
on va l'éliminer donc ça c'est un autre
exemple quelque chose qu'on ferait
différemment
très bien mais si vous manque d'argent
pour aller que vos promesses vous dites
ça n'arrivera pas mais c'est arrivé
les 15 dernières années c'est arriver
les premiers ministres ont dû faire des
choix
ce que vous dites ou canadiens je serais
prêt à mettre de côté un certaines
promesses pour ne pas plonger le pays en
difficile
c'est absolument l'inversé de ce que je
viens de dire nous allons maintenir
l'ensemble de nos engagements nous
allons les réaliser ce sont nos
priorités
quand je dis c'est une priorité pour moi
que les personnes âgées les aînés qui
vivent dans la pauvreté en laissant de
la pauvreté c'est que ça va être une
priorité lorsque viendra le temps de
faire notre projet il ya certaines
choses que faisait monsieur rappelé que
nous offrait pas très bien nos choix
n'est pas un jeune en allégeant par noah
monsieur mulcair est ce que vous allez
mettre moins d'argent dans la défense
nationale par exemple mais la défense
nationale va faire l'objet d'une
attention particulière parce que
monsieur harper a fait beaucoup de
promesses pour l'achat d'équipements
militaires il n'y a rien qui a été dit
vrai que ce soit pour les brise glaces
pour les f 35 qui sont tous au total 45
milliards donc encore une fois on va
regarder ça parce qu'en termes
d'administration publique monsieur roy
il ya rien de plus simple et de plus
élémentaires que de dire on va faire un
appel d'offres est le plus bas
soumissionnaire conforme va avoir le
contrat est ce que je voudrais bien
parce qu'elle tu t'arranges de mal
compris ma vie vous dit est ce que vous
dites qu'il ya peut-être des économies à
faire du côté de la défense nationale ce
que je suis en train de vous dire c'est
que monsieur harper est en train de
dépenser 45 milliards de dollars sans
même faire un appel d'offres alors
wilfart fort à parier que dans ce seul
exemple la des chasseurs pour l'armée de
l'air qu'il ya des économies à faire
bien sûr très bien monsieur mulcair vous
avez dit très clairement que vous ne
feriez plus partie de la coalition
contre le groupe armé islamique donc ça
veut dire est ce qu on comprend bien que
si vous êtes élu premier ministre le
lendemain et le 20 octobre appelée barre
obama et vous dit vous ne comptez plus
sur les avions canadiens dans votre
coalition qui regroupe je vous le dis en
passant 22 pays de la planète
exact le npd est résolument opposé à au
bombardement par le canada dans cet état
leur rappelant que tous les traits j'ai
dit qu'on voit à l'écran et on n'essaie
pas de diminuer l'horreur qu'on voit
mais tout ça c'est le résultat de la
dernière guerre mal avisé de 2003 en
irak
donc on va pas répéter les erreurs du
passé vous dites qu'il ya une coalition
mais attention
moi je suis en faveur du
multilatéralisme dans ces états unis
l'allemagne la vous le savez comme moi
oui par contre ce n'est pas une mission
de l'otan ça c'est justement un alliance
dont on fait partie où on a eu des
obligations ce n'est pas une mission des
nations unies non plus en vertu du doubs
devoir de protéger moi je vais regarder
si c'est une montagne si vous avez donc
c'est clair et net
la réponse est claire et native on se
retire alors j'ai une petite question
en terminant si les actions du groupe
armé islamique ne justifie pas à vos
yeux une intervention militaire
qu'est ce qui pourrait le justifier sur
la planète actuellement mais je vais
vous donner un exemple concret le
premier nessma appelé pour savoir si
j'accepterais s'il avait l'intention
d'utiliser les gros-porteurs canadien en
mal et j'ai donné mon accord
il n'avait pas besoin de permission mais
j'ai exprimé mon accord parce que
c'était la bonne chose à faire
le npd a voté en faveur de la mission
contre kadhafi en libye rappelons le
c'était il ya à peine quelques années
parce que c'était en vertu d'un mandat
des nations unies sur le devoir de
protéger des civils donc on était pour
quand ça s'est transformé
avec les amériques et notamment en une
mission pour changer de régime nazi est
ce que vous savez pas quoi ça va être
remplacé je pense que l'histoire nous a
donné raison monsieur roy on a vu que
justement ce qu'il l'a remplacé de la
sorte les gars aussi mauvais monsieur
milquet j'avais plein d'autres questions
le temps passe vite jouée et équitable
avec tous les chefs donc si terminé on
aura l'occasion de se reparler
parce que la campagne c'est un cliché de
le dire mais ne fait que commencer dans
le fond
d'accord ben oui et j'apprécie
énormément ce temps ce soir monsieur roy
puis j'ai très hâte de pouvoir continuer
la discussion remercierai bien au revoir
la première fois